frankfurt zwei den käfig oder was geht
hier ist euer kran und heute gibt es
einfach ein bisschen pvp hier auf timo
ja und ich habe einfach kein bisschen
bock drauf weil na ja wie soll ich sagen
ich habe die ganze zeit schon so wie es
in mir gegönnt hayek rang 42
dies geht auch schon gut los
sie trank viel trank fahrzeug also wir
sind voll mit irgendwelchen hacker
menschen in einer runde
aber wir müssen es die entscheidung alle
können hier dass wir auch von herzen
kommen alter schwede wir zu kämpfen
das nicht mehr normal ich kenne das
schon von von sk ich bin ich schlagen
bin ich kein zweites mal durch die so
gar nicht schlagen
herrmann sieht es nicht wenn ich schlage
ich habe japan scheint irgendwie so ein
innovations- fehler gerade aber geht das
schon gut los hier mit einem hacker
gelten heckert rang direkt ich glaube
den hatte alter mann kann hier einfach
alles abbauen
das ist ja richtig krass ich kenne das
eigentlich so dass man sofort viele
herzen hatten so was und ja ok sämtliche
die halten können alter schwede das zu
recht ein bisschen strange alter alter
das ist echt mal na ja irgendwie das
gefühl dass ver.di habe ich auch mein
gegner heute noch 94 herzen leute das
ist natürlich ärgerlich
nee also an sich habe ich die ganze zeit
ppp gespielt weil ich einfach bock drauf
hat also es ist so richtig gut die ganze
zeit und ich habe mir dabei irgendwie
ein verändertes angeschaut so was mache
ich hier eigentlich vor gerne in letzter
zeit und wir habe ich ein paar
angeschaut und dabei habe ich einfach
gesagt ja und jetzt dachte mir nämlich
das für euch auf und es lief also
wirklich stark so die runden davor
wahrscheinlich sieht man eben hier die
face camp den rahmen noch mal so ein
bisschen zurecht
er läutet das ist professionalität und
ein hitzerennen damit er nicht dieser
weiße rand ist jetzt zwar aber ich lasse
es jetzt einfach so also an sich ja hat
bock drauf vielleicht ich glaube heute
sollte auch war training kommen sorry
aber ich finde wohl ein bisschen blöd
die keine ahnung haben server verdeckten
kräfte kommen natürlich ein morgen war
wobei doch morgen kann beim training
kommt profitiert hatten wir aber gut
jetzt gegeben dass zwei herzen hat dann
auch dafür kommt morgen beim training am
mittwoch kommt wieder um 18 uhr
community clash
ich verrate noch nicht gegen wen es
gehen wird aber es wird wieder sehr
spannend werden
und ja dann wird wahrscheinlich
irgendwie morgen oder so was wieder
aufgenommen ich weiß noch nicht genau
okay das wieder der derselbe gegner von
gerade eben jetzt macht euch auf energy
musste ich ja nicht unbedingt mitmachen
also weil es dauert immer so lange finde
ich man klar der sollte ein spaß haben
und zuletzt wärme von unten
klar hat er nicht so die chancen denke
ich neun halb herzen nach ja aber ich
glaube ich ein bisschen besser kann ich
schon spielen wenn ich mich nicht nicht
darauf konzentrieren muss halt zu
kommentieren aber gut glaube da gibt es
weniger bei dem das anlass ist ganz
klassisch heiße also entfernt abonnent
von computers zu ihr seht ihr bestimmt
auch schon hier texture pack habe ich
auch schon daheim alter also wirklich
ich habe davor dass jetzt auch nach
aufnahme verklebte vor glaube ich keine
ahnung irgendwie 20 gespielten habe
wirklich keine irgendwie verloren oder
so also es lief richtig gut aber wir
hatten ja schon das eine oder andere
aufregende erlebnis zu beginn drin
der hat anscheinend gar keine lust hier
zu spielen fragt man sich natürlich
warum er dann geht es wieder der ganz
klassisch leute das war das ziel
dem hits auf jeden fall okay ja-wort
aber irgendwie irgendwie war es gerade
komisch ich weiß es nicht und ich bin
gerade einfach nur schlecht ich schreibe
es in die kommentare aber irgendwie fand
ich gerade die die hits echt verdammt
strange den camp ich jetzt ich kämpfe
irgendwie immer nur gegen zwei
unterschiedliche du vielleicht ein
bisschen länger warten oder andere lobby
gehen oder so was
ich kämpfe immer nur gegen diese zwei
jahres war der gegen den king den kenne
ich gerade das dritte mal oder die haben
einfach nur alle sein kind aber ich
glaube das ist die ganze zeit der gut
hier also bogen welche natürlich auch
noch in ein mit spannen animation
reinpacken
einfach weil es besser ist weil pvp
christian direkt 3000 besser aber sie
dürfen zum beispiel die schwerter und
warst du mit mir drin behalten
jetzt habe ich ganz ähnlich viel
geschrieben oder welche mich ausreden
konzentriert wenn ihr das seht dann
denkt euch ein gp auf jeden fall das
pack ich nur noch ein finde ich cool
dass meine schwerter drin haben kann und
dass man auf das eigene gi drin haben
dachte ich weiß gar nicht ob fadenkreuz
und sowas ob man das darf aber ok power
oder wie auf der rüstung wahrscheinlich
jahr wurde er war mein läuft ja ganz gut
diese runde er lag halt leider ein
bisschen aber hat eigentlich volle
connection weiß ich nicht genau woran es
liegt aber ich finde es immer also ich
finde es interessant einerseits dass man
diese ganzen unterschiedlichen kids hat
einfach für für abwechslung und sowas
und andererseits ist es aber auch mega
strange wenn man dann halt irgendwelche
wie soll ich sagen
crash kidz hat sowie das sie zum
beispiel so vollkommen übertrieben so
mit 3000 metern noch beck und sowas
finde ich immer ein bisschen ein
bisschen komisch aber was soll's so so
research angefangen das wollen wir gut
die die tränke geben jetzt gleich haben
behaupte ich mal getränke neuen
halbherzig sieht man natürlich den
elften rang davor gegönnt
ich denke wir werden einfach so zehn
minuten spielen jetzt wieder und dann
lasse ich das dabei nach wegsteckt ihm
werde ich wahrscheinlich weniger
brauchen
anstatt wenig feile glaube ich nur okay
ich glaube gegen den habe ich freu mich
schon mal gekämpft jetzt nicht in der
aufnahme ok na gut ich war relativ
eindeutig aber manchmal so ich habe das
auch manchmal dass ich mich einfach
verschätzt so ob ich jetzt ob jetzt
anfangen soll zu boxen oder umziehen
oder sonst was
daher kann ich das relativ gut verstehen
ich weiß nicht wie viele wissen
natürlich auch ein nachteil wenn man
wenn man ich glaube alle erstellen
eigentlich ein dass ihre eigenes kind
behalten wollen einfach weil weil sie es
gewöhnt sind außer mir leid ich hätte
halt irgendwie hat lust auf
unterschiedliche catch can ja das dann
bei so was ist immer blöd wenn man darin
fängt partie zu beenden aber der andere
nach hinten kann ja auch leute
wir haben so ein bisschen die heiße
phase überlegen habe ich das gefühl also
jetzt draußen temperatur mir ist gestern
war es einfach 40 grad und ich war den
ganzen tag unterwegs aber trotzdem
coolen tag gehabt aber war schon ganz
anständig bei 40 grad
da draußen auf den street zu sein
präsent zu sein in der hut und klar so
ein haufen scheiße
jaja leute kennt man nicht auf
so hat sich seinen eigenen links
mitgegeben haben wir doch perfekt also
an sich läuft ganz gut auch nochmal
mikrofon sollte ich wobei jetzt weiß ich
dass er nicht mehr an weil sonst habe
ich wird es an einer stelle im video
viel zu laut oder anderen titel also
sein aber das muss ich auf jeden fall
deutlich hoch kegeln ja aber das geht am
anfang war doch sehr gut ich weiß nicht
so krass geschockt weil ich das erkennen
von meinem bruder sk aber ja ich hab
jetzt werden wir schon bessere geschäfte
geben bisher müssen probieren ihm eine
combo zu geben aber der einem ok vier
herzen er hat mich viel besser getroffen
anfang aber ich denke mal also ich habe
jetzt so das gefühl dass ich schon
entdecken besser noch bin als ich die
letzten wochen als unsicher scheiße na
gut was soll ich da machen hier seit 18
ich hoffe dass das bei wahrung nicht
vorkommen wird oder dass es wenn es
vorkommen nicht mehr vorkommen wird mit
unsichtbar und sichtbarkeit was hab ich
glaube wir treten ja nur auf wenn server
gleichzeitig 17 und 18 also sowas aber
lasst mich nichts falsches sagen mir
nicht ganz sicher
denn so sehr schön aber ist ja auf jeden
fall drin der tut mich jetzt nicht
getroffen aber der dürfte uns gehören
okay da hab ich jetzt auch wieder für
die framerate auch mein pc nochmal
einsätze aufsetzen vor warum alter
richtig laut ps für eine ich habe besser
angefangen gerade ja ich glaube hat der
infinity ward eine begrenzte anzahl von
fällen aber weiß ist nicht genau klar
wer gewinnen wird er ja nach der combo
auf jeden fall heiß gemacht drei kämpfe
und dann lassen wir das gut sein für
heute so heißt es aus vollkommen kräftig
sonst finde ich die finger irgendwas
herum zu entscheiden
jeder kämpft auch direkt hier sehr schön
hat aber noch einen pfeil davor bekommen
ich wollte mir das probieren
auszuweichen
ich hab dich immer aber jetzt dürfen
ihnen relativ weit haben ich weiß nicht
was der eine rüstung hat da drin aber
vorbei
die hält schon gut was aus so hatte ich
für kranke grant ich habe überhaupt
keine lust mir das alles durch zu
schauen was der da drin hat er gut aber
ich hab so wie gesagt das gefühl dass
ich mich ein bisschen besser jetzt
schreibe nur so gewinnt so richtig
intense habe ich es gar nicht die idee
sondern wie gesagt denkt euch das wenn
ihr das seht weil dann ich kann nicht
jeden fall nach dem kampf zu schreiben
nicht direkt in den schrank ihm seine
fraser ich habe dann meinen er soll
ruhig rennen weil in der zeit kriegt er
halt schaden und mir passiert gar nichts
volker probieren mir sein
links zu können jetzt hat der medien
transportieren ganz schnell zu erledigen
alter kann man damit nicht auftauchen
ich konnte einfach nicht auftauchen
aber ich glaube da sind unsichtbare
blöcke sodann ich glaube ein kampf gibt
es noch zu machen sind natürlich
probieren easy energy diesen kampf zu
beginn zum glück ist das peinlich
geworden ich hab noch fahrer aufnehmen
müssen dann hätte ich nicht gemacht
drei sekunden okay das kann ich gar
nicht überleben er hat mich jetzt nicht
so übertrieben gut getroffen
da haben wir ein okay da schauen wenn
jetzt wieder relativ froh aber ihr könnt
nicht alter der combo schade
ok misst leute also aufnahmen effekt ein
bisschen würde ich sagen ich habe
wirklich davor ich dachte okay jetzt
machst du so eine aufnahme wurde so
alles auseinander boxt aber es war auf
jeden fall immer relativ knapp relativ
spannend auch lustig mit dem ding am
anfang habe ich sagen das was von heute
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen einfach
mal wieder was alleine habe ich glaube
ich schon länger nicht mehr gemacht aber
das war cool hätte ich nicht so viel
gesprächsthema aber trotzdem ganz viel
spaß gemacht